[Music]
my sister Fernand and I grew up loving
animals our best family vacation was a
trip to Disney's Animal Kingdom I was
five years old and I went on the safari
right when I saw their reenactment of
poachers trying to steal a baby elephant
my heart beat so hard I still remember
how it found it when the elephant was
rescued this was Disney after all I
cried with relief lil did I know that
one day Fernand and I would have our own
rescue mission six years ago we made a
tiger he was living in a small town in
Mexico in a public park where the
government couldn't afford to pay for
his medication his home was a windowless
concrete heart full of all filthy Hey
the Tigers name was Raja which means
Indian King but Raja was in the sort of
majestic creature you'd expect to see in
a Disney movie he was so weak he
couldn't even stand up he had red bra
open sores on his legs when I looked at
Raja and I really looked into his deep
dark watery eyes I could feel his misery
and all I wanted to do was to take him
out of that concrete prison and find a
place where he could go and be healthy
and safe again trying to find such a
place
Fernanda and I contacted a number of
sanctuaries finally one in color I
agreed to take Raja after countless
meetings and phone calls and paperwork
over an eight week period we finally
convinced the Mexican government to let
go of fragile but before we could do
that transport Raja died but Fernanda
heard the news we held each other and we
decided that we would do everything we
could to prevent other animals from
sharing Rajas unhappy ending in 2015 we
had our first test mexico's Congress
passed a well intentioned law that
banned animal performances from circuses
from one day to another 1,200 animals
needed a new place to live the lack of
suitable places to relocate these
animals resulted in the death of a
thousand of them Fran Anthony started a
social media campaign
we contacted International centuries and
we talked to the Mexican authorities and
then we learned that this was just the
tip of the iceberg in the past 15 years
in Mexico alone 45,000 wild animals have
been victims of abuse exploitation and
wildlife trade and the wounds that were
lucky enough to be rescued didn't have a
safe place to go sadly this is a problem
that goes far beyond Mexico according to
the world's wildlife organization
environmental degradation together with
illegal wildlife trade has led to an
extinction rate between a thousand and
ten thousand times higher than the
natural extinction rate since 1976 we've
wiped out 66
zero percent of the world's wildlife
recently the last male white rhino died
there are still two female white rhinos
in the planet but when they die the
whole species will be gone forever
the heart of the problem lies in the
lack of awareness about wildlife
conservation in some cultures rhino horn
is used as if it was a miracle cure in
others ivory is a symbol of status but
it's not just exotic products that harm
wildlife if you use shampoo or eat ice
cream these everyday products typically
contain palm oil every hour rainforest
area equivalent to 300 soccer fields are
being lost to pump all firming leaving
hundreds of wild animals and endangered
species homeless thankfully most of the
time when people learn about the
negative consequences their behaviors
have they start caring each one of us in
this room can make a difference by
changing some of our behaviors in 2017
Fernand and I decided to build Latin
America's first wildlife sanctuary to
house and rehabilitate abused wild
animals located in 50 acres in the
center of Mexico sand why is being
designed to accommodate 200 wild animals
including bears elephants and big cats
through the best veterinary practices
and top-notch facilities our sanctuary
will provide these animals with a
healthy and safe place to live in
Central visitors will be able to witness
the consequences of illegal wildlife
trade and environmental degradation but
they will also learn ways in which they
can contribute to the solution our end
goal is to replicate this kind of
sanctuaries across the world currently
we're in the process of raising funds
and hopefully in
few months we will be able to start
building the place that will change the
lives of hundreds of wild animals but
most importantly their behaviors and
minds of thousands of visitors however
you don't have to build a wildlife
sanctuary to make a difference minor
changes in your everyday habit could
save the lives of hundreds of wild
animals a few people have asked me why
should I care about saving wild animals
well let me tell you biodiversity is
fundamental for a healthy ecosystem a
healthy ecosystem is fundamental for a
healthy and sustainable economy
these animals are fundamental part of
that biodiversity but mostly I just want
to show them a picture of Raja to me the
reason why we need to save these animals
is self-evident there are many things
you can do to help protect well animals
but today I want you to live with three
in mind first reduce food waste 40% of
the food grown in the planet is wasted
growing that food destroys habitats
so let's not grow so much more than we
need
second by environmentally responsible
products look at the ingredients make
sure they are responsibly sourced
especially if it contains palm oil third
reduce meat consumption try to shift
from red to white meat the livestock
industry is responsible for a
disproportionate amount of annual
habitat destruction
then you can always volunteer or donate
to sanctuaries like mine today I feel
very lucky to be part of the GSB
community people like you have the power
to inspire thousands of others through
the companies you will create through
the policies you will influence and
through the children you will raise
let's all work together in creating
real-life happy endings for animals like
preju thank you
[Applause]
[Music]